this video was sponsored by dashlane
conveniently store your passwords and
get 10% off for the first 200 people to
use the link in the description it's now
2019 and everything is getting old Ellen
DeGeneres is now 60 comments on why I'm
wrong about Florida's flag are getting
ancient not that I read those or
anything and Millennials are now
officially full grown adults the
youngest are graduating college and
entering the job market the oldest are
well into their careers and while some
companies are busy complaining about
Millennials killing their business
others are realizing hey this generation
might not be exactly the same as their
parents and are adapting imagine that
hence lots of bright colors artsy fonts
emojis and manufactured authenticity
probably not a great time to announce
the new poly matter branding one of the
most successful of these companies is
called we work in case you're not a
twenty to thirty five year old who lives
here and likes to work from a beanbag no
judgment here's the idea
instead of leasing an office for a whole
year or trying to write a script about
this hot new startup called a we work in
a Starbucks while the barista yells
Karen for the seventh time in two
minutes you can rent a space in one of
we works 500 buildings in 97 cities for
somewhere between two and eight hundred
dollars a month you get a private office
a desk or the opportunity of a desk
they provide the Wi-Fi furnitures
printers and cleaning it's got all the
ingredients of a fun exciting young
startup craft beer pictures of people
doing yoga and chairs that don't look
like chairs it may not sound
revolutionary but it's perfectly timed
with the rise of independent remote and
freelance workers who there are now 68
million of in the US alone there's just
one problem or a few billion actually we
work is the 4th highest valued startup
in
world just behind Oberer and its chinese
competitor many have called it massively
overvalued even the most overvalued
meanwhile it's starting a school called
we grow a gym called rise by we and
renting apartments called we live which
all sounds a wee bit scattershot
so what's the deal the answer is just as
interesting as what it says about our
whole economy the way we work makes
money or tries to is actually pretty
simple it is starting to buy a few of
its own buildings but for the most part
here's how it works
first it finds big centrally located
buildings in young densely populated
areas and signs a 5 10 even 15 year
lease which makes the landlord really
happy at least for now and then they
turn around and sublease to you and i on
a monthly basis pretty simple right a
little too simple you might be thinking
if we work can make money appear out of
thin air by splitting a big lease into a
bunch of tiny ones why doesn't the
building just do that itself isn't we
work just an inefficient middleman
instead of paying one landlord now we're
essentially paying too and that's true
nothing stops the owner of a building
from creating its own shared offices
some do but it's not so simple for two
reasons first we work and the owner are
really playing two very different games
at its core we work is one giant forty
seven billion dollar bet that it's real
estate will increase in value because if
you and I pay more every month for a
desk we work still pays the same ten
fifteen whatever year lease and they
pocket the difference on the other hand
if can I say when property values fall
they have to pay the difference
now each lease is under a different
subsidiary so if it can't afford to make
payments the company as a whole is
somewhat protected but if a bunch of
them fail
the same time like during a recession it
could be really really bad and remember
that most of weworks customers are small
startups and freelancers you know the
businesses most likely to fail during a
recession oops the owner on the other
hand gets a consistent arguably lower
risk paycheck and makes its building
more valuable in the mean time the
second reason is that we work has an
unfair advantage
unlike the property owner it can set
prices unreasonably low attracting far
more customers the secret is that we
work is always on sale you just don't
know it how can it sell a service for
less than what it costs the answer is a
little actually remarkably not so little
company called Softbank you've never
heard of it because it's a multinational
holding conglomerate in English a
company that owns companies a big pile
of money softbank's vision fund is
nearly 100 billion dollars provided by
Saudi Arabia the United Arab Emirates
and companies like Apple and Qualcomm
best friends I here to put that in
perspective because frankly anything
over like six zeros tends to look the
same these are the other biggest venture
capital firms the vision fund makes even
Goldman Sachs look more bronze than gold
so what does it do with all that money
mostly invest in tech companies and when
those run out anything that remotely
looks like one basically add big data or
blockchain to your name and then buy a
bigger wallet because Softbank wants all
of it just a few weeks ago it poured
another two billion dollars into we work
and if you think that's a lot which it
is it was originally going to be 16
billion so Softbank in a roundabout way
is paying for part of your office and
hopes that the company will grow and one
day make a profit which is all too
common
enjoy those $1 scooters and cheap uber
rides because some venture capitalists
somewhere is paying for them it
won't last forever just ask anyone with
movie pass how that turned out but hang
on
why does Softbank who likes tech
companies like uber and byte dance
invest in we work who leases real estate
well that's the question is we work a
tech company or does it just really want
to be because if it's just a middleman
between property owners and renters and
uber just a platform connecting drivers
and riders both of which use technology
but suffer the economics of a non tech
company then they're a lot less exciting
if that's true a lot of investors are
spending a lot more than they should and
when they realize this things are going
to get ugly
think about it this way a tech company
can potentially have seven billion users
instantly a thousand downloads doesn't
cost any more than one scale is nearly
unlimited and therefore so are
valuations we work however we'll always
have to buy or lease more space as more
people join it scales but not in the
same way to put it in perspective
there's this other less exciting
co-working company called Regis this is
its total square feet and this is we
works again with a valuation of 47
billion so what's Regis valued at four
billion that's not with a zero hmm oh
yeah and fun fact
Regis actually makes a profit I know
right who does that so old-fashioned
the question is what makes we work worth
that extra forty three billion why is it
valued like a tech company and Regis
based on you know how much money it can
make now it's tempting to stop here to
say we work is just a real estate
company and yes it's overvalued but
that's not totally fair there's a reason
we work is so much more successful and
it's not just that Softbank thinks its
money is a hot potato
it's because we work has mastered the
art of telling a story Regis has nice
professional photos and
advertises with generic phrases like
stay productive but we work understands
the Millennial big art pieces craft beer
and so many mentions of the word
community that I'm afraid to control F
their website for fear of crashing my
browser quote we work is a state of
consciousness a generation of
interconnected emotionally intelligent
entrepreneurs roll your eyes all you
want and trust me I have but it works
and it does have useful data on where
people work when their most productive
and so on which they can use to redesign
and optimize buildings that's valuable
information it has to decide for example
how many conference rooms to build based
on how much they'll be used that's worth
a thousands of dollars a month because
if it builds even one too many rooms
it's wasting space that could have been
a desk and made more money so is it a
real estate or tech company yes but make
no mistake its core business
fundamentally relies on property values
that's true no matter how hard it tries
to distract us Hey look over here we're
not just a real estate company we're
building a high-end gym in New York we
bought a wave pool company seriously
though why and we're starting an
elementary school which by the way costs
up to $42,000 a year a total of three
hundred and eighty eight thousand
dollars from age two to eleven although
to be fair it's no ordinary school quote
a field of super elliptic objects forms
a learning landscape that's dense and
rational yet free and fluid whatever
that means it's not enough to save the
company from the fate of regis who after
the dot-com crash filed for bankruptcy
to survive its first recession we work
will have to change its strategy or
significantly diversify its income
economic downturns are inevitable you
have to protect yourself by spreading
your eggs across multiple baskets
likewise it's only a matter of time
before the next big hack and when it
happens you don't want to be the guy
with the same or similar passwords
across all your accounts - Lane
and conveniently store and fill those
passwords so you don't have to and since
you're not remembering them you can make
them ridiculously long and hard to guess
there's even a built-in VPN whether you
use Windows Android iOS or Mac you can
easily download their app and start
using it for free if you're like me
you'll be glad you have it every time
you log in or create an account or buy
something online you can sign up
completely free with a link in the
description and the first 200 people
will also get 10% off premium